plus de 500 manifestants dans les rues
de lyon malgré la situation sanitaire à
l'appel du collectif de soutien aux
réfugiés et migrants lyon 69 ils
réclament la fermeture des centres de
rétention administrative notamment celui
de l'aéroport de lyon-saint-exupéry des
établissements où sont retenus les
étrangers en situation irrégulière avant
d'être expulsés vers leur pays d'origine
devant des lieux symboliques comme la
direction interrégionale des douanes de
lyon
les membres de ces collectif dénonce une
politique anti immigration
il s'oppose à la liberté de circulation
et d'installation pour les étrangers
alors que les citoyens français ont le
droit de circuler et de s'installer
librement là où ils veulent
c'est une politique xénophobe c'est une
politique contre les étrangers et nous
estimons que cette politique xénophobe
elle a une raison politique c'est de
désigner des boucs émissaires pour
détourner l'attention sippley les
étrangers comme responsables coffrini
reprendre le travail ou d'avoir des
logements ou des aides alors que le
gouvernement français réduit de façon
drastique
tous les droits sociaux y compris pour
les français ces manifestants pointe
aussi les conditions de rétention qu'il
juge indigne les centres administratifs
six ans de prison
pour les sans papiers dans ces centres
la loi des familles il y à des femmes
mais il ya des encore aussi
ils ont pas ils vont droit d'écrire que
parce que le gars assez ici en france
c'est collectif dénonce en outre des
rétentions prolongé en raison de la
fermeture des frontières à cause de la
pandémie de kobe de 19 ils demandent la
régularisation de toutes les personnes
étrangères en situation irrégulière des
revendications éloigné des intentions de
l'exécutif
le nombre de rétention administrative
est en hausse en 2010 9 53 mille
personnes ont été détenues dans ces
centres ces 23 % de plus que l'année
précédente
parmi elles près de 4000 enfants des
rétentions qui ont valu à la france cinq
condamnations de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme malgré ces sanctions
la création de quatre nouveaux centres
de rétention administrative annoncé la
même année par christophe castaner alors
ministre de l'intérieur a été maintenue